[Music]
and let me tell you it will fight back
ghosts like to fight for example 1813 a
group of mediums went into the house
just a little north of here it's a 21
days they work their butts off and they
got that deceased owner out of there but
they were all found
how old are you
nine okay I'm talking organs on the
outside China's young it's not that
young girl I was driving by nine look I
know that might have been an extreme
example yes they were a group of
amateurs I am a professional okay I'm
bona fide and qualified certified and I
can get rid of what died
oh
no
pumpkin what's wrong this place is
haunted all right now hang on I know
this place isn't as warm as I'd hoped
but you know I think we get some
daylight in here it's gonna feel better
hey I'm gonna light a vanilla candle and
it's going to be a game changer
eyes far apart close average I think of
normal average
okay average but they were a bit uh
sunken into the recesses of his occupy
it's like a raccoon I sit back
his eyes were doing that and no eyelids
so they're into a skull no eyelets what
about his nose no nose you know no nose
why would he why would he have a nose oh
he was smiling the man who mugged you
was smiling but he didn't have lips it
was kind of like a Perpetual smile at
swords it's kind of like yeah like that
it's kind of exactly yeah okay ellipse
why not I would have lips
just the man who mugged you
wow
you just did that just now this is
amazing you know it'll be fun
see him with skin
maybe I'll just do a little blessing a
prayer to get us started on the right
foot
God give us a break we can we don't want
to be haunted
it just seems like there's so many bad
people in the world I want them how
about an amen at the count of three one
two three amen
amen are you sure he's a priest now if I
can communicate with William Gracie
I suspect he will have the answers that
we need and just to confirm the only
thing available to us is this French
vanilla Yankee Candle yeah I keep
forgetting to
that's my subscription to Amazon so
please hold hands
[Music]
okay okay okay
come on
sir can I look
when you hear something
in Haunted Mansion I wanted everything
to feel as if it came right off of the
ride when I walked through the set oh my
goodness it's powerful to see it the
level of detail from the bus down to the
wallpaper you just felt like this really
feels haunted it's kind of amazing
seeing the Haunted Mansion come to life
foreign
the details that fans remembered and
expand the universe around them
y'all just do a little blessing get us
started God give us a break amen the
thing that makes the ride so cool is
that the Mansion already as a history
this place is legendary and our
characters are discovering it if we
don't solve this mystery we're stuck
here for eternity
for me the secrets of this movie was
always going to be the Ensemble it was
one of those great casts everybody loves
each other we bonded it was fun to go to
work every day it was so much fun we
laughed a lot it's a unique story with
moments of levity and fun and there's a
lot of obscures as well
when audiences come out of the theater
I want them to be like whoa wait a
minute hold up I'm scared but I want to
do it again
around every corner
[Music]
I'm gonna get up you can keep rolling
wait let me detach my you see behind the
scenes right let's see what happens
[Music]
see what I mean did you see that the
Haunted Mansion of this Walt Disney's
last ride that he had a hand in
developing this place is legendary
there's so much genius already there we
want it to stay incredibly true to it
but when I walked through the set oh my
goodness you feel like you got out of
the chair of the ride and you got to
walk around that was surprising I really
marveled at the detail put into the sets
the scale it was pretty overwhelming I
was just in awe the whole time these are
not just little movie sets these are
beautifully constructed pieces of art
when I walk down these cavernous
hallways I start getting that creepy
cold feeling that lurks around every
corner
on this film we were really lucky that
we got to go to the park after hours a
very special private tour there was just
so many details to pull from the
graveyard Stones The Best of the hit the
suit of armor Gliding Over the dining
room we all know what we want out of
this going to the right told us where we
needed to fill in and where we needed to
go bigger to make movie scale
I'm excited that people get to see it on
the big screen and be immersed in it
but there's always
one more big trouble the Mansion is the
start of the movie we are merely chess
pieces within it
it's like wild
[Music]
when my son and I moved in here
it wasn't as warm as we hoped
okay I'm gonna light a vanilla candle
and it's going to be a game changer
and after midnight the house comes alive
this place is haunted
we need your help
it's time to assemble the Dream Team
we find someone who can communicate with
these ghosts
people used to eat here
told you she's good it's a dining room I
found a professor who else wanted
mansions I've been dying to go to this
place for years
mystery lurks around every corner
[Music]
I can show you what happened but it will
cost you
three dollars
what silent robbery who said that
you're not that scary you're really not
you're pretty terrifying can you turn
around just while I finish this up thank
you
guys
yeah I'm seeing it
if we don't solve this mystery
we're stuck here for eternity
you're all in for a treat
foreign
[Music]